Bitcoin mining is the process that  generates new bitcoins here's how it  works first we need a mining program and  a computer with enough power to solve  extremely complex problems the problems  that you're solving are software  algorithms that are used to validate  recent Bitcoin transactions once a  problem is solved and the transaction is  complete the computer server that solved  it is issued a reward in Bitcoin the  entire process is designed to mimic the  production rate of a commodity like gold  but here's the catch just like gold  there's a limited supply of bitcoins 21  million to be exact and earning new ones  gets harder and harder as new bitcoins  are generated  you